えええ
兄
w
l
文化アナリストって聞いたことある人い
ます
あれっあー
の家族じゃないですか
a 基本的にはですねぇー
あのいないと思いますなぜかというと僕が
勝手に作ってからです
でなぜかと言いますと6かいろんなの社会
活動をしようと思ったときに自分のやり
たいことと
その既存のまぁ既にある方書というものが
町マッチする事ものがありませんでした
あった写真で作ったらいいだろう
例えば夜中では何とかメディア
クリエイターとか言いますよね
そんな感じでまあいい続けてればその内に
定着するんじゃないかと思っています
本日は実は幸せのついての話をしたいと
思います
なぜ幸せの話かといいますと実はこうこの
研究には大きく分けで3つの当てゴリが
あります
一つ目は
脳科学とか心理学の話ですねこれはまあ
一番あの主流の話でみなさんがよくご存知
かもしれません
そしてもうひとつは昔は良かったけ
a これにライトですね
根拠がなかったりするんです実際にデータ
がなかったりとか
まあ幸せな明日菜とよく出てくるブータ
ンっ
自作です
持続可能性のことだってとか普遍性店で
ちょっと疑問が残ります
2つは3つ目
何かというと文化社会環境の影響がどの
ように人々の幸福
インパクトを与えているからっていう役な
んですがこれほとんどされてないんですだ
から本日は国際文化あまりさとして
廊下ですね
実際のそのいろんなデータを分析しながら
解説したいと思います
実は
が以前
see you トレーラーですね
外姿勢のアメリカの証券会社で仕事をして
いました
これは
金から金かどうやって可能向かって言う
非常にシビアな世界だったんです
そんなある程度その収入的にはまぁそんな
悪くなかったんですけども
でも
僕は幸せじゃありませんでした
じゃあ
どうすればいいか他に自分が何をすれば
いいかって考えたんですけどもでもあのし
たいか本当は分かりませんでした
だったらじゃあも基本的にもう自分自身の
その発想根底から覆すが
いわゆるパラダイムの変化みたいなのこれ
が必要ばなんじゃないかと思いました
じゃあどうしたら腹に変換できるかという
ともう自分で進行
知らない分からところにさまま逃げて
しまう
それによってもういいだろと聞いたところ
ないようなの人生から外最初から着替える
ような
そんな
経験をする必要があるんじゃないかと
他はもう会社辞めました
そして
水かの環境を変えて旅に出ました
最初は3年で世界を旅するつもりだったん
ですけども気がついたら10年経ってまし
た
本当はですねこのたびの話たくさん面白い
のあるんですけども日本でちょっと時間が
ないのでここで割愛させていただきます
でまぁもしあの
てデックとかが3時間くらい話しさせて
くれんだから
その時また呼んでください
でその旅を通じてですね
一つ大きく気がついたことがありますそれ
は
人を幸せにしやすい社会
そして人を幸せにしにくいじゃないという
のが
あるということに気がつきました
具体的に
どういうことかと言うとまず者に殺戮です
日本の自殺一というのは世界でも第7番目
ぐらい
かなり高いですただこの自殺率の統計を見
てみると上位
30カ国中の20カ国が実は
旧共産主義とアジア
ここに独占されています
そうしますとじゃあ一つ疑問が出てきまし
た
そもそも社会っていうのは
何度かになるのか
この
一つの簡単な答えがあります
個人の幸せなんか目
だって
その社会を構成している
その一人一人が幸せにならなかったら
じゃあ一体それは社会が何のためにあるん
意味わかんないですね
だ
日本の交付を見てみましょう
概念カーみたいな無法
概念っていうのはどういうことかというと
こういう条件を添えると人が幸せになる
だろうということを客観的にインデックス
化したと言ったです平均人のだったりとか
たまたま人だかり準備
式神とかそういう条件ですねこれを見ると
日本の抱負ドって意外と高いんですよ世界
でも結構トップレベルです
だから
結構日本人の皆さんがいやー日本っていう
のはすごくシャア作為だよっていうのは
ある程度
根拠があるんじゃないかなっ
こういうところが入ってるんじゃないかと
思うんですが
ただ一つ大きなまだ日本が残ります
何かと言うと
やそもそも
幸せというのは
誰がてみてください
もし何が山田こうなったら幸せだという
ことをいくら入ってるんですね
自分自身が
その幸せを感じてなかったら
全く意味ないですよね
じゃあ日本人のこういった内面から見
たーーー
どういう一幸せと感じているか
これを見ているんですね意外と低いんです
よ世界の中でもだいたい真ん中ぐらい
そして先進国の中ではこれはほぼ最低です
チラ見
1958年から日本の人仲間 gdp って
いうのは約6倍に上がりました
でもその間の生活満足度ねあ幸福度という
のも言えるかもしれないんですがこれは
横ばいです
この館たとえば1980年代後半のバブル
積極
日本の
経済が世界を圧巻して失業率1%ん
今を言われたような社会問題一切ありませ
んでした
そんなことでさえ
生活満足度
変わってなかったと
こういう話をするといやそれは日本人展
なんか dna が違う
なく田の問題だけどね皇族考えるから
いらっしゃるかもしれないんでそこで一つ
非常に面白い
いたします
旧東ドイツと刑にしろう
この2つには1990年
の壁が崩壊するまで
45年間
一つは共産主義一つは正直全く違う
システムの中で一つの壮大な社会実験が
行われました
この2つの国っていうのは民族も言語全く
同じですよねでも例の壁が崩壊した後
旧共産主義の
東ドイツっていうのが一貫して
幸福度が低い
これはじゃあ社会システムがどれほど人々
が幸福度に影響を与えるかという非常に
良い
例だと思います
でこの次がですね
主観的幸福の幸福感とあと1頭 gdp を
比べたものなんですが赤いところですね
ラテンアメリカ
そして青いところが旧共産主義国です
ちょっと見にくいかもしれないんですけど
もまぁ簡単に言うと
なぜアメリカと旧共産主義国というのは
経済的な規模ではほぼ一緒です
でも幸福度でみるとラテンアメリカの形と
いうのは
圧倒的に幸福度が高いです
僕も辞さ2年ほどですねなあアルゼンチン
いたんですけども間違いないです
非常に効果が高いです今でいきたいです
ねっ
ジャミン日本は
gdp
高い場合には
幸福度は結構低いです
人種
これは
国土には関係ないです
非行
関係ないです
まあよくねあったかい友達ってのはなんか
すぐハッピーじゃないかと思われること
いるかもしれないんですけども
実際統計見ると全く関係ないです
収去
関係ないです
じゃあどんな環境が人を幸せにするん
でしょうか
あります
自ら選べる範囲が広い
つまり自己決定権が広い
そういう地域が幸福度が高いってことです
ね自己決定系
どういうことが
自分の属性に関係なく人生を止めることが
できるか
まぁコレ一つれーなんですけれども大学
防止性ねあればその人が男であるとか女で
あるとか
そういうことによってした人生が着替えて
しまうのか
日本は残念ながら
世界142カ国中1054です非常に弾
熟女指数悪いですね
これは言い換えると社会の寛容道という
いいから持ってきますじゃあこの稼業
これをどうやったら調べられるか
実は一つ非常にわかりやすい
腫瘍があるんですよ何かというとどこの
社会にも必ず存在する minority
少数派の人たちがその社会でどういったし
ニンテンを得ているか
これを見てみるとわかるんですね
この地図は
世界の同性愛の結婚が認められている
ところ青いところが認めているところ
そして
茶類
ウェンジのところなんですね同性愛である
ことが
違法であって最悪試験なる地域です
なぜどうせあの話かといいですね
あなた自身だ
同性愛者であるかどうかというのはそれは
た実はこれ実際
設定できません
あなたが自分でそう感じるかどうか
それだけですよね
ということはその感じるという自分の花
医師によってその意志がどれだけその社会
がリスペクトして
ちゃんと守ってくれるか
こういう寛容度が高いということなんです
だから同性愛結婚の
が合法化されているところっていうのは
軒並み幸福度が高いです
でこれは
集団主義の
構造的な問題
どういうことかというとそもそも集団主義
というのはコレ
みんなと同じことをしてください
これ週刊誌んですね
ただ幸せってなるかなにかかなぁとやっぱ
これは人それぞれ
じぶんまくらなきゃいけない
っていうことはですねじゃあ集団主義で
ある限りは幸せというのはどっかで頭町
なっちゃうんですよ
例えばじゃあ日本人
痩せほしいですかっていう話を聞き立つ
すると安は当然みんなだそうです
でもじゃあ実際休み食べましたか
いうとみんな撮ってません
日本人の有給休暇消化率
これは世界最低でいます
じゃなんで休まないんですか
いうと
よっ
岡野やすい他の台も休み取らないっ
ねだから個人がやりたくないことであった
としてもみんながいるからだからそう言わ
なきゃいけないっ
まぁちょっと非常に危険な
脱がせ
あかんくでしたね
でその行き着く果てが過労死ですよ
つまり
生きるために働く明日が働きすぎて死んで
しまうまあ自分のホームは戦闘な欠陥だっ
てしまう
ただですね
じゃあその集団主義っていうのは[ __ ]の
人間かというと実はそうではないんですよ
なぜかというと
準備というのは
c ランシーから始まったからです
だから
問題としては集団主義とかいうことじゃ
なくてこれは文化を完全に超越した
歴史的な必然なんですね
例えばて思いやりとか絆
協力
こういう言葉は特に震災後
非常に言われました
日本人だね特質団体話はよく出てくるん
ですが違います
人で共通です
重い思いやりとかどこの国でもどの社会で
も必ずあります
だから
これは射程として取り組んでいた大きな
課題として
個人を請求すること
そして
集団をそれをどうやっており衣をつける
さん
ここが問題なんですよね
歴史的なその中で見るとコピーものがより
ジジュン
動い
こういうプロセスがいいてきます民主主義
これは典型的な例ですよねそして共産新
これは究極の集団石です
そしてインターネットはオープン総数こう
いったものというのはつまり社会から
個人の方に決定権が映されてい
もう一つ本当は逆には戻れないということ
ですよね
まあそう言ってるんですね
その集団に属したい人に見てもらえると
いうことはこれは幸せを感じる大きな要因
でもあります
ただ
集団に自分自身同化させるということで
その集団に承認されるということは結局は
自己
最終的な否定することになって
シュート半端な中丹
それしか
発生されない
集団主義の前提っていうのは要するに
みんながみんな同じ事やりなさいとっても
の仕事をやると同じことはやらないと
社会がバラバラになっちゃうからって言わ
れますつまりどういうことかというと個人
の能力を歩い否定してるんですよねこれは
ミソです
完全に洗脳です
実際個人の幸福追求というものと
そして社会にこれは矛盾しません
例えば
人権の問題とか教育問題経済のか経済の
問題あとは地方分権とかね色んな今社会
問題
鳥ずされているもあるんですけれどもこう
いった問題というのは
ある意味自己決定権を拡大していくという
こういった同じテーマで見ることができ
ますただこういった例えばその時点の男女
共同なんで元男女協働しなきゃいけないん
ですかなんで少数反面人権もなきゃいけ
ないんですか教育令や腰の可能性された
サケキャン穏乃日目ですか
起業家精神
ラーマ彼にそんなことしなきゃいけないん
だ超文系なんですか
この答えが実は
幸福の追求です
これが全く
幸せの為にあるんだと言う
皆が同じ目線で同じゴールを持って社会
問題を解決することが可能なんですん
最後
皆さん質問したいと思います
あなたは
なのだも言ってるんですか
この省に対して
即答でですね
や幸せのためだ
こう答えることができたら
そこでやっと出発満たすことができます
なぜかというと
そこで初めてじゃあどうしたら幸せになる
かっていうことは
考えことができるからです
そして
その社会構成している
一人一人が
幸せのために生きてるんだっていう
考えてことができるんだったらそこで
初めてじゃあその社会がまんまからなんだ
死者はそのためにあんですよねって言う
構成させが取れるんじゃないでしょうか
作ります
はぁ